edit vient de vendre sa maison il ya au
moins une chose dont il n'aura pas à
s'occuper
le choix du notaire si son acheteur qui
s'en charge
eddy est convaincu que c'est aussi
l'acheteur qui va payer les frais du
notaire comme le veut la tradition
pourtant une fois la vente conclue celle
à nos terres et 10 à une surprise
elle lui réclame des frais de 400
dollars c'est une tendance qu'on voit de
plus en plus les notaires refile une
partie de leur facture aux vendeurs ça
leur permet d'attirer les acheteurs avec
un prix alléchant et c'est légal parce
qu'une partie du travail de la notaire
consiste à s'assurer qu'aucune des tlet
associés aux titres de propriété des 10
elle lui fait donc payer cette partie de
son travail
1 s'il l'avait su avant d'arriver dans
le bureau de la notaire et d y aurait pu
tenter de s'entendre avec elle ou lui
proposer autre chose à son acheteur le
fin mot de l'histoire
vous vendez votre maison éviter les
surprises
renseignez vous auprès du notaire de
votre acheteur